hmm
yesterday
is
oh
good morning
good morning good morning thank you mr
president and for inviting me to join
today and thank you for convening us all
today
today is an exciting day for our country
and i want to begin by thanking pat
gelsinger the ceo of intel and intel for
making this massive historic investment
in american manufacturing right here in
america
now from day one president biden has
recognized
and been clear that if we want to
compete globally
we have to invest domestically
and he's prioritized the revitalization
of our manufacturing economy
and given those of us and his team a
crystal clear mission
to get those jobs back from overseas to
america
and thanks to the president's leadership
our economy added almost six and a half
million jobs last year the most in any
year in u.s history and our unemployment
rate dropped nearly 70 percent
make no mistake about it by any measure
the united states economy is strong
but the fact is
car prices are currently driving a third
of inflation
why because we can't we don't have
enough chips last year automakers made
nearly 8 million fewer cars than they
could have because of the semiconductor
chip shortage
electric vehicles for which the
president has set an ambitious goal 50
of new car sales by the end of the
decade
require 2 000 chips each ev requires 2
000 chips more than twice as many as a
traditional vehicle
so that's why today's announcement from
intel is so exciting
semiconductors produced right here in
america will allow us to shore up our
supply chains bring down cost keep
manufacturing facilities up and running
and create american jobs
but if we really want to end the chip
shortage and ensure our global
competitiveness there's more to do
today our semiconductor supply chain is
far too dependent on conditions in
countries
halfway around the world
a cove disruption a typhoon political
instability in another country
has the potential to shut down an auto
facility and harm american families in
places like ohio
the semiconductor industry was created
in the united states of america and it's
time for us to lead again
right now
right now there's a bill before congress
that would invest 52 billion dollars in
semiconductor production
congress needs to pass that bill
to revitalize america's domestic
manufacturing passing that chips funding
is a win for workers businesses supply
chains and our economy
so again mr president thank you for your
leadership and thank you to intel for
choosing america
it's now my great pleasure to introduce
pat gelsinger the ceo of intel
uh he's a global leader in the
semiconductor industry has been a leader
in the industry for decades and the
announcement he'll be making today will
create nearly 12 000 jobs in total and
it's a perfect example of what we can do
if we invest in america's manufacturing
industry again so with that i will turn
it over to pat
thank you secretary romando thank you
president thank you for my best ohio
friends and the senators
and uh we look forward to being welcomed
into ohio i am thrilled to be at the
white house today such an exciting
occasion historic day for intel and
the global semiconductor industry and
for a farm boy from pennsylvania i
thought i'd never be here
today intel is announcing plans for an
initial investment of more than 20
billion to build two new leading edge
fabs in ohio
i would be remiss not to thank governor
dewine and his team in ohio for their
fantastic partnership and i look forward
to commemorating this special day
together at our event in lincoln county
ohio later today
this will be our first new manufacturing
site in 40 years and spanning nearly a
thousand acres will be a mega fab
location that can accommodate a total of
eight chip factories or fabs as we call
them what we're announcing today is the
first two but we hope to build out that
full campus this initial investment is
20 billion the single largest private
sector investment in ohio history and we
plan to continue to grow this presence
you know at full battle out the site
could alone could grow to as much as a
hundred billion dollars of total
investment over the neck over the decade
this impact of a mega site like this is
simply profound a semiconductor factory
is not like other factories it's more
like a small city supporting a vibrant
community of services suppliers and
ancillary businesses you can think about
this as a magnet for the entire tech
industry and all of this is creating new
jobs and we plan to invest an additional
100 million over the next decade to help
develop and attract a pipeline of skill
talent and bolster research programs
throughout the region
intel's investments will help meet the
unprecedented demand for advanced
semiconductors or chips as they are
called
as every consumer in america now knows
we've seen disruptions in our supply
chain globally many products are in back
order and you know christmas trees were
not nearly as full this year simply
because the industry does not have
enough chips our lives depend on them
and ponder for a moment what portion of
your life is not becoming more digital
our dependence the criticality of
semiconductors the brains that are
powering critical industries education
business medicine work from home learn
from home care from home infrastructure
national security
all of these depend on ships
but as secretary raimondo said most
semiconductors today are sourced
overseas as a country we cannot rely
solely on imports for such essential
technology and the only way to address
this economic and security risk is to
increase our domestic semiconductor
manufacturing capacity that's why last
year i announced a historic investment
to expand our operations in arizona and
mexico and as the company who put
silicon into silicon valley and the
company that is now the catalyst for the
silicon heartland
intel is committed to restoring
end-to-end leadership innovation and
manufacturing here in the u.s
we are doing our part
but
we can't do it alone
the federal government has shown strong
bipartisan support for growing the
strategic industry and i'd like to thank
president biden secretary raimondo and
everybody involved in this supporting
the semiconductor industry and i would
also like to thank senator schumer
cornyn and representatives matsui and
mccall for sponsoring the chips for
america act
but as secretary romano said
now congress needs to finish the job
our announcement today
is motivated by the chips act we're
putting our chips on the table
as i like to say we are getting started
but this project will be bigger and
faster
with the chips act the chips act will
help address the long-term impacts of
the semiconductor shortage global supply
chain challenges and associated rising
costs faced by american families today
it will also ensure america maintains
its leadership role in semiconductor
manufacturing and r d
we welcome the opportunity to work with
president biden federal and state
governments to transform the turmoil of
this time into a recovery that creates
world-changing technology to improve the
life of every person on the planet i
thank you
and it's now my honor
my pleasure and something a farm kid
from pennsylvania would have never
imagined that i get to introduce the
president of the united states mr
president
thank you
well you've introduced the kid from
scranton pennsylvania i didn't think it
either so
it's great to be with you
pat thanks for the introduction and this
is a truly historic investment
in america and american workers
this group of washington reporters have
heard me say many times
it's never been a good bet to bet
against america
we have the most qualified folks in the
world here in the united states of
america
and i want to thank
sherrod brown and rob portman two
senators who deserve an enormous amount
of credit for us getting to this place
right now
bipartisan
the idea that we can work together is
always just beginning to dawn on people
here i think
and i want to thank commerce secretary
gina raimondo who from day one has been
helping lead our efforts to strengthen
american manufacturing in america
and american innovation
look
pat just laid out today's big
announcement
by one of america's most important
companies
this historic investment for ohio one of
the largest investment in semiconductor
manufacturing in american history
a brand new 20 billion dollar campus
outside of columbus ohio
seven thousand construction jobs
three thousand full-time jobs and i was
kidding pat earlier i said i may need a
job and i said well it's not bad you
start over a hundred thousand bucks
online but i gotta get some training
but
to be able to say
made in ohio
made in america
but we used to always be able to say 25
30 years ago that's what this is about
but folks at home might be wondering why
such a big deal for manufacturing
something so small the size of a postage
stamp why is that so important well
semiconductors are small computer chips
that power virtually everything in our
lives
your phone
your car
your refrigerator your washing machine
hospital equipment the internet the
electric grid and so much more and
here's the deal
america invented these chips
america invented these chips
and federal research and development led
to the creation of these chips
taxpayer dollars
these chips help our nasa mission to the
moon
the federal investment helped bring down
the cost of making chips to build a
market and an entire industry
as a result over 30 years ago america
had about 40 percent of global
production
but since that time something happened
american manufacturing
the backbone of our economy got hollowed
out
companies moved jobs and production
overseas especially from in the
industrial midwest
decades ago
we used to invest two percent
of our gross domestic product in
research and development said again
we invested two percent
decades ago of our gross domestic
product in pure research and development
today it's less than one percent
we were ranked number one in the world
in r d
but guess what
we now rank number nine
china was number eight in the world
three decades ago
now they're number two
and other countries are closing in fast
as a result today we barely produce 10
percent of the computer ships despite
being the leader in chip design and
research
we don't have the ability to make the
most advanced chips now right now but
today 75 of production takes place in
east asia
ninety percent of the most advanced
chips are made in taiwan
china is doing everything it can to take
over the global market
so they can try to out-compete the rest
of us and have a lot of applications
including military applications folks
look
during this pandemic your pocket felt
the consequences inflation higher prices
whenever a factory shuts down in one
part of the world
the production and shipments of goods to
shops and homes and business all over
the world gets disrupted
covet 19 has compounded that problem
many times over especially with these
computer chips as a result everything
from cars to dishwashers are delayed
getting to showrooms and customers just
as demand for them is up because the
economy's growing
and because supply is low
because supply is low we find ourselves
in a position that we're really behind
the curve prices are going up
in fact one third of the recent price
increases have been seen nationally are
due to car prices as mentioned earlier
you know
can i i'm going to turn to the boss here
what percentage of chips are needed to
build the cars today and what's going to
happen in the next five to ten years
four percent today 20 by 2030. 20
by 2030
is going to be required to that's that's
that's what the car is made of
20 of it it's going to be computer chips
historic as today's announcement is
we need to be this is just the beginning
this is an important part of today's
message
right now there's a bill in front of the
united states congress because the two
men behind me are pushing it u.s
innovation and competition act which
includes several of the ideas i proposed
last year that would accelerate the
progress in a big way
the bill calls for authorized nearly 90
billion dollars
for research and development
manufacturing and supply chain
look including empowering the national
science foundation to bring together
local communities universities community
college private companies and more and
more partnerships like this and by the
way speaking of community colleges
you all know this the the washington
press cordos elise my wife is a
community college professor she said
it's the best kept secret in america
this is a community college graduate
who skipped his senior year in high
school went to local community college
and then went on
my wife's got to meet you man
look this includes a 52 billion dollar
incentive for more companies to build
their manufacturing fields here in the
united states america
i want other cities and states to be
able to make announcement like the one
being made here today
and that's why i want to see congress
pass this bill right away and get it to
my desk let's get another historic piece
of bipartisan legislation done
let's do it for the sake of our economic
competitiveness and our national
security
let's do it for the cities and towns all
across america working to get their
piece of the global economic package
let's do it for the dignity and pride of
this country and the american worker
i made clear while i was running for
president
and from day one of this administration
we are going to invest in america we're
investing in american workers we're
going to stamp everything we can made in
america
especially these computer chips
vice president harris and i along with
secretary armando and our entire team
had met with members of congress in both
parties because this is a bipartisan
issue
we brought business and labor together
to see where we could ramp up production
and help resolve bottlenecks soon after
i was sworn in i signed an executive
order to revitalize american
manufacturing and making our supply
chains more resilient to disruptions
whether it's a pandemic climate change
or cyber attacks
in some cases building resilience will
mean increasing our production here at
home you know doesn't mean working more
closely with our trusted friends and
partners nations that share our values
so that the supply chains do not get
used against us as leverage
in fact i made this clear
to president xi of china we need not
have confrontation
but we have a stiff economic and
technological competition and we're
going to insist everyone including china
play by the same rules we're going to
invest whatever it takes in america in
american innovation in american
communities and american workers that's
exactly what we're doing here today
as a result of the progress we made
record economic growth record job growth
faster economic recovery than any other
nation on earth
we are better positioned globally than
we have been in a long long time
intel's historic investment is one
example
it's not the only one in fact last year
the largest semiconductor companies
including samsung and micron
invested committed 80 billion to build
new facilities united states in arizona
new york oregon texas
and why are these companies choosing us
the united states i think it's because
they know we're the most productive
workers the best research universities a
dynamic venture capitalist system and a
rule of law that protects intellectual
property
i think we're better positioned than any
nation
any any nation to seize these
opportunities but we have to keep it
going
i think our best days ahead of us
last year we took a big step toward that
front with the bipartisan infrastructure
law and i want to thank senator brown
and senator portman for their hard work
and getting that done that law is going
to upgrade everything from roads bridges
ports airports
transit to make our economy move faster
and reduce prices for families this is
going to create better jobs for millions
of americans all over the country
rural urban suburban and it means
america is the most attractive place for
companies like intel to invest and make
their products
because of the law
this year for the first time in two
decades our infrastructure investment
will grow faster than china's for the
first time decades this is a game
changer
now now we have to build on that
progress and that's what this day is
about it includes congress acting on our
competition bill which i mentioned
earlier
my administration is going to keep using
all the tools we have to reassure our
supply chains strengthen our economic
resilience and make more in america
because the end of the day
this is about national security economic
security and it's about jobs
good paying decent jobs you can raise a
family on
jobs jobs now
jobs for the future
jobs in every part of the country jobs
that show
bring the industrial midwest back
it shows the world that we're always
going to fight for american workers
in fact
these facilities are a symbol of what
america is all about
ph.d engineers scientists alongside
community college graduates as my wife
says their best kept secret in america
went on beyond that but people of
different ages races backgrounds working
side by side
they're all working together to do the
same thing
the most sophisticated manufacturing we
have ever seen
tiny computer ship the size of a stamp
they're showing what i've always
believed
there is nothing
nothing beyond our capacity as a nation
if we do it together as the united
states of america
i want to thank pat again intel
i can't wait to see uh
see this uh this next visit that you're
about to have in uh in ohio today and i
want to make one last comment
you know folks um
and i asked pat this but i've asked many
other
corporate leaders around this nation
this
when the american when the united states
of america when the government
makes a decision to invest considerable
amounts of resources in a new industry
or in an area that we need to build up
that encourages business to say they're
doing it
this is going to happen i'll get in too
i asked pat whether that was part of the
judgment am i misleading am i mistaken
at all
and it is but i just want everybody to
understand
when you know uh
i'm sure there were people who looked at
both my colleagues who helped lead the
fight and then this chips act were
trying to pass one are you gonna spend
all that money
that money attracts money
it attracts investment
it demonstrates we're all in so folks
i'm to say what i've always said there's
not a damn thing this country can't do
not a single thing we can't do
you've heard me say it before and i'm
going to say it again
i was talking to the i spent about an
hour and a half today with the japanese
prime minister on a visual on a virtual
meeting with our status
and
i told him about when
president xi asked me can i define
america
when i was in eight when i was in china
with him i said yeah
one word
one word
possibilities
possibilities
we can do anything
if we put our mind to it
god bless you all to make god protect
our troops and by the way the reason
we're not going to have any time for
questions now is these guys got to get
quickly on the plane and go out and do a
major announcement in ohio and you guys
will ask me all about russia and not
about anything having to do with chips
how are we going to guarantee the raw
materials will be available since many
of them are come from without
the united states including some
countries like afghanistan
we're working on that there's a lot not
in afghanistan there's a lot of we've
been finding out and moving on
directions to find where the raw
materials are we're making contracts to
make sure we have access to them and we
are doing things that we find out here
in the united states we some have assets
we didn't know we had in terms of raw
materials
thank you
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
come back to tell us about russia when
you cancer